we're back yeah Hannah biess is
officially hitting the road with the
Dancing with the Stars live tour that
means we'll see more fun moments like
these as she rejoins Kate Flannery for
six stops beginning next month
perfect so does Hannah's new gig finally
put to rest rumors that she's the next
Bachelorette there is this like weird
like that is still something a desire of
my heart to find somebody do I have to
do that in as being the Bachelorette no
the Bachelorette starts shooting in
March so if Hannah's on tour there's no
way she's the chosen one I'm just asking
for the truth then who is in the running
well two of Pilate Pete's final picks
Hannah Ann or Madison our options and
Kelsey aka
champagne girl has already proven to be
good TV
[Music]
okay what what the hell though we've got
our eye on Tia booth she scandal-free
and remember she dated Colton Underwood
but who does pilot Pete like Kelly would
kill it and went there you guys in front
of buses Kelly you so ready Kelly is one
of the smartest people I've ever met I
think she can make an absolute amazing
one
[Music]